У школярів канікули, а вчителі працюють.
Ось і вчитель історії 157-ї київської школи
Сергій Берендєєв на роботі до самого вечора.
Йому лише 35, але вже має 15-річний вчительський стаж.
Викладає кілька предметів: історію, правознавство,
громадянську освіту. А ще веде класне керівництво:
у нього підлітковий 10-й клас.
- У тебе робочий день завершується лише тоді, коли ти лягаєш спати.
Весь час ти проводиш в різноманітних підготовках.
Проте офіційно в Сергія 26 робочих годин.
Збільшити його робочий тиждень до 40 годин
пропонує партія "Голос". Мовляв, так держава
чесно визнає, що вчителі працюють більше.
Такі правки до законопроєкту про повну загальну та середню освіту
обговорюються наразі в Верховній Раді. Натомість
учителям пропонують суттєво збільшити заробітну платню,
однак скасувати при цьому всі надбавки.
Сергій і багато його колег бояться, що на практиці
це призведе до зменшення вчительських зарплат.
У Сергія ставка - 5000 гривень.
Ще 5 тисяч він отримує за рахунок надбавок:
за класне керівництво, за адміністративну роботу,
доплату від столичної мерії тощо. Чому він
проти ініціативи "Голосу", показує на прикладі простого рівняння.
- За проектом "Голосу" виходить, що я буду отримувати
5 тисяч гривень.
Це враховуючи, що я маю вищу вчительську категорію.
Така калькуляція - не зовсім те, що пропонує партія "Голос ".
Учителі неправильно все зрозуміли, запевняє DW
одна з ініціаторок таких змін,
колишня заступниця міністра освіти, а нині
народна депутатка від партії "Голос" Інна Совсун.
Вона стверджує, що насправді мета "Голосу" -
саме підвищити зарплату вчителям.
- Відповідно до наших правок, якщо б вони були
втілені з 1 січня наступного року, то заробітна плата
вчителя становила б від 8 500 до 18 000 гривень.
Сьогодні середня зарплата вчителя становить 7 300.
Це суттєво менше, ніж пропонується нашими правками.
Радянські правила нарахування зарплат
- за надбавками - ініціатори правок
до законопроєкту хочуть змінити
відповідно до європейських стандартів.
Дати вчителям просто більшу зарплату, щоб вона
не залежала від надбавок. Приміром, немає сенсу
окремо платити вчителям за перевірку зошитів,
оскільки вони й так це роблять за програмою.
Учителям не треба перевантажуватися і брати
на себе більше роботи, аби заробляти більше.
Усіх педагогів пенсійного віку хочуть перевести
на роботу за строковими угодами.
Зарплата педагога має залежати не від вислуги років
чи стажу, а від рівня кваліфікації.
Залежно від категорії це автоматично означатиме
підвищення вчительської зарплати на 20-40%.
У "Голосі" також вважають, що треба офіційно
збільшити до 40 годин тривалість робочого тижня
для вчителів, бо де-факто вони стільки й працюють.
Однак такі пропозиції викликали хвилю обурення серед освітян.
- Залишається повністю гола ставка.
Це неможливо. Ми в категорії викладачів
і ми отримуємо набагато менше, ніж прибиральниці.
- Я ще пенсіонер. Я проживу ще , в мене пенсія є.
А молоді спеціалісти? Що вони будуть отримувати? По 3 000?
А хто тоді буде працювати?
- Хочуть, наприклад, за класне керівництво зняти надбавку.
Це буде взагалі катастрофа, тому що це дуже важко.
- Я хочу, щоб права вчителів не порушували.
Вчителі мають право на гідну зарплату,
на гідні умови праці, на повагу від влади.
- Перед тим, як щось робити, ти прийди в школу,
в дитячий садочок і поспілкуйся з людьми.
Зсередини треба знати проблему.
Київські вчителі вирішили використати осінні канікули
для боротьби за свої права. Поки йшли до Верховної Ради,
слухали пісні Вакарчука, а коли дійшли - відреагували на його появу обурливими вигуками.
(натовп гукає): Ганьба! Ганьба!
Голова партії "Голос" Святослав Вакарчук
такого явно не очікував. Він намагається запевнити
вчителів, що не є їхнім ворогом. Навпаки: хоче, аби
їхня праця була гідно оцінена.
- "Голос" - ваш союзник. Ніколи не дасть вас образити…
Вчителі не вірять таким запевнянням і
вимагають від влади відмовитися від запропонованих правок.
Міністерство освіти частково підтримує освітян,
а частково - "Голос". Міністерка Ганна Новосад
повідомила, що не згодна з запровадженням 40-годинного робочого тижня.
Проте вважає, що система оплати педагогів справді
має бути реформована. За словами Новосад,
кількість надбавок треба зменшувати, але
за рахунок внесення цієї суми в посадовий оклад.
Та вчителів це не заспокоїло. Вони вимагають
відкликати поправки, і лідер "Голосу" поступився.
- Що стосується правок, ми чуємо вас.
І всі ті правки, які сьогодні не на часі, їх не буде. Дякую.
Першою приберуть пропозицію щодо 40-годинного робочого тижня.
До всього іншого, за словами Вакарчука,
повернуться після того, як буде збільшена базова ставка
зарплати вчителів. Для цього "Голос" вимагатиме
в уряду збільшення видатків на освіту в бюджеті на 2020-й рік.
- Нам би дуже хотілося, щоб у цей бюджет
було включено підвищення зарплати вчителям.
Щоб ви розуміли: бюджет на наступний рік,
за розрахунками профспілки, передбачає, що
витрати на освіту складуть 5,6% ВВП.
Це є скороченням у порівняні з поточним роком,
тому що сьогодні видатки на освіту становлять десь 6,2% ВВП.
Аби прогодувати свою родину - безробітну дружину
і двох маленьких дітей, - учитель Сергій Берендєєв
вимушений підробляти ще на двох роботах.
Сергій вийшов на протест, бо вважає, що партія Зеленського
має виконати свою обіцянку і дійсно зробити освіту пріоритетом
і почати з підвищення зарплатні, бо через
низьку оплату праці лише в київських школах нині
не вистачає майже півтори тисячі фахівців.
Страйк! Страйк! Страйк! Страйк!
Освітяни  не виключають, що знову прийдуть
під стіни Верховної Ради відстоювати гідну оплату праці
і право брати участь в обговоренні змін до законодавства,
адже останні поправки про оплату їхньої праці
не виносилися на громадське обговорення.